being a software engineer sucks I was
told I would be working in a fast-paced
exciting environment but in reality I'm
stuck in this cubicle building super
complex stuff that nobody understands or
appreciates if I had a time machine I
would do two things one I would tell
harambe to get away from that kid
and two I would go back to school to
become a civil engineer so I could work
outside building stuff everyone admires
like Bridges and skyscrapers
unfortunately I haven't figured out how
to build a time machine in JavaScript
yet now I would never recommend anybody
choose software engineering as a career
but if you do make bad life choices like
me you should be prepared for some
really bad things to happen like every
doctor eventually loses a patient and
every pilot eventually crashes a plane
likewise every software engineer will
eventually face a merge conflict and
that's not even very bad in today's
video we'll look at seven different
devastating text messages that no
developer ever wants to hear speaking of
which I finally started a Discord so
feel free to chat with me over there
after this video we've got some T-shirts
and licenses to jetbrain software to
give away over there one of the biggest
problems with software engineering is
that you don't want your friends and
family to find out what you do the
reason is you'll get messages like this
from your uncle or old roommate asking
if you want to build an app together it
will consist of a very dumb idea that's
impossibly complex to execute like uber
but for horses or Tick Tock without the
Chinese with a 5 hundred dollar budget
messages like this are so painful
because software Engineers are usually
introverts who have a hard time saying
no what you'll want to do is respond and
say hey that's an awesome idea I would
love to build it for you but my rate is
300 an hour what they'll likely do is
come back with a counteroffer of zero
dollars per hour but 10 equity in the
company which will eventually be worth
billions that's pretty much Checkmate
trust speaks for itself I would just
recommend accepting the offer and
building the app to get them to go away
now when you're not building apps for
friends and family you should be working
on your own side projects and in doing
that you'll likely use the cloud like
AWS one of the worst messages you can
receive is a cloud billing alert like
hey it's AWS your 25 budget has been
exceeded by 2.3 million dollars maybe
you click the wrong button or
accidentally created an infinite Loop
but the important thing here is not to
panic the easiest solution is to just
stop using AWS and pretend nothing ever
happened if Jeff ever sends his guys
after you just tell them your account
got hacked that may or may not work and
if it doesn't you can at least find
comfort in knowing there are many other
homos people out there who simply forgot
to turn off an ec2 instance another
dreaded catastrophic thing a developer
doesn't want to hear is that a
production database has been dropped
accidentally along with all of your
company's data that was worth billions
of dollars you just made the simple
mistake of dropping prod instead of Dev
when something like this happens it's
absolutely terrifying but hopefully you
have backups that are able to restore it
back to its original state if not now
would be a good time to start looking
for a new job dropping a database is
incredibly easy and can be accomplished
with a single line of code you can use
this knowledge to fight back against the
system as this person did here by
weaponizing SQL injection against speed
cameras dropping a database is bad but
at least it's over quickly many
developers suffer a worse fate like this
guy who got a message from his boss
assigning him to a legacy angularjs
version 1 code base that needs to be
migrated to angular 14. sadly the
previous developer died of old age and
was the only one who had any idea how
anything in this code base worked he
knew exactly how to keep his job by
creating an overly complex code base
without any comments or documentation
and now it's your turn to update it [ __ ]
my life this job will take more skill
and Ingenuity than building a nuclear
submarine and when you finally finish
the job in a few years no one will even
notice or care because by that time
it'll be time to migrate your legacy
code base into the hot new JavaScript
framework of 2025. speaking of which
something a web developer never wants to
hear is that a new better JavaScript
framework has been invented when you
learn a JavaScript framework you join a
tribe and that means everything outside
that tribe is dangerous and terrible now
normally you can create an echo chamber
to convince yourself that your chosen
framework is absolutely 100 the best in
every use case however at some point you
may be convinced that a better framework
does in fact exist when that day comes
you'll need to turn your back on your
tribe and lose many friends in the
process and it's not exactly easy to
make new friends when you're a software
engineer
can't sit here but one of the most
annoying things that can happen to you
is when a non-technical person like a
client or marketing expert asks you to
make one small change to an already
finished product like let's just move
this nav bar from the top over to the
side here it should be an easy change
for you to make you don't not want to
look like a 10x developer so you go
ahead and do it but it takes like 20
hours and modifications and 800
different HTML and CSS files then as
soon as you commit your work that same
person will come back and say you know
what I think I liked it better the first
way let's go ahead and change it back
it's no secret that the most important
skill of a software engineer is being
able to Google things effectively that
means one of the worst things that can
happen to you is running into a problem
that nobody else has already solved for
you it's painful enough when zero
results come back on Google with your
error message but an even worse thing
can happen you might search an error and
get a single result on an obscure Forum
from 10 years ago and find some dude
going through the exact same problem as
you as you scroll down hoping for a
well-documented and detailed solution
you find that all he posted was fixed
all good now and now you have to figure
out the problem all by yourself being
the Chad that you are you get to work
and as soon as you're about to solve the
problem you get a notification that it's
time for your daily stand-up meeting
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one